well let's take you back to the United
Nations Headquarters in New York a
summit to discuss the sustainable
development goals is underway K's prime
minister shik Muhammad B Abdul Rahman
Alani is addressing delegates let's
listen in of to the United Nations has
been entrusted with the responsibility
of facilitating government negotiations
on the uh political declaration in
cooperation with his Excellency the
permanent representative of Ireland to
the United Nations we are gathered here
at this very itical moment in the
implementation of sdgs where we share
one goal addressing the most urgent
challenges facing the world armed
conflicts food security crisis and
climate
change needless to say commitment to
Peaceful settlement of
differences and respectful
dialogue our best to safeguard the
development G gains worldwide therefore
we must give priority to the
implementation of effective procedures
and measures as per the international
law to remove the difficulties hindering
the right of self-determination for
those living under foreign uh occupation
including the Palestinian people it is
also crucial to avoid any steps that
would undermine the ability of
developing countries to implement
sustainable development goals including
imposing coercive measures in a manner
contrary to the United Nations Charter
and the principles of international law
Mr
President in this occasion we should
assert that investment in the future of
our youth Falls to all of us and by
appreciating the opinions of Youth
empowering and empowering women and uh
girls and involving them in decision
making we can build more inclusive and
sustainable communities the vital role
played by the state of Qatar in
development worldwide especially in
education enhances the vision of the
state in human development we are
committed to supporting the
implementation of the Doha program of
action for the least development
countries recognizes recognizing the
challenges facing these countries the
state of Qatar is committed to the
alignment of its National development
plans with the sustainable development
goals principles Kar has made the
climate change a top priority and has
taken important measures to develop the
relevant techniques Mr President in the
end let us remember that the pathway to
build a new world that is safer more
Equitable and free is through achieving
international human solidarity together
we can turn our commitments to action
and turn the 2030 agenda into reality
thank you very
much well that was kata's prime minister
shik Muhammad bin Abdul ramman Alani he
was speaking at the United Nations
Headquarters in New York at a summit to
discuss the sustainable development
goals uh that has just got gotten
underway he said Kat Shar the goal of
addressing the major issues facing the
world including armed conflict climate
change and hunger well let's bring in
Patty khain again who is at the United
Nations there in New York what else did
uh qatar's prime minister
say well he did talk a lot about um the
and obviously a lot is in the scope of
they're only all allowed five minutes
because there's 11 11 of them to get
through today but he did talk about
education and the statistics from the UN
and when it comes to education are
alarming 84 million children are not in
school right now that has a huge knock
on impact for future Generations he
talked about the rights of women and
girls and this was a statistic given by
the UN that was somewhat shocking it
said only about 50 Le less than 50% of
married women worldwide have control
over their own reproductive uh rights
and so women and girls and education a
huge focus of these 17 different planks
that they are seeing complete slides
back on um and one of the things that I
I think is notable is the number of
refugees it is the highest on record
just try and keep this in context
because I know these numbers can sound
overwhelming but we're talking about
individual people making heroine
Journeys 34.6 million this uh in the
past year 41% of those were children so
these are huge Global issues and one
that they've said and again this is the
halfway point one that they said that
they were going to really change in the
next by 20 30 and they are nowhere near
in most of their goals and and Petty
obviously we know that countries are
dealing with high inflation there's the
global economy isn't exactly doing
particularly well at this point in time
there's also the war in Ukraine that is
putting a strain on many countries I
mean even if there is the political will
to do something here I mean is there the
money to do
it and that is one of the things that
they say needs to change especially the
Secretary General he says we've
basically got to completely change the
way uh the world financing the world
banks are operating have to change the
way debt is being serviced in developing
countries and that they really at the
core of all this as you mentioned
governments need to spend more money
propping up Social Services for
education for health care for
infrastructure and really right now
because everybody's so uncertain about
the global economy I mean how many times
have we been in the US talking about our
recessions coming next week next month
and two months and that's just in the
United States we've seen a lot of
developed countries backsliding dealing
with high inflation numbers really
worried about what's going to happen in
the future so it's not clear that
they're going to be able to come up with
this money they say is desperately
needed if they're going to stop the
basic reversal of most of these goals
okay thank you so much for that that is
petty Khan for us at the United Nations
in New York